You know,
I've kind of wondered about this gender flexibility issue as a form of delayed
fantasy play.
You get Friday and on the go ahead because it looks to me like that is,
you know,
when kids are little and three and four,
say three to seven,
they do a tremendous amount of identity play.
You know,
they pretend they're animals,
they pretend they're their parents,
they,
they pretend they're girls.
If they're boys,
they pretend they're boys.
If they're girls,
like they really do a tremendous amount of identity play.
And one of the things that's been really puzzling me is,
well what happens if that isn't,
um,
if they never have an opportunity for that because they're not engaging in
fantasy play,
maybe it's just delayed til adulthood.
That's interesting.
So because played,
it's almost impossible to overstate the importance of that rough and tumble play
and then the fantasy play that enables you to adopt different identities and
then then negotiated games that you talked about that enabled people to handle
both,
both victory,
but even more importantly loss.
So that's possible.
That could well be.
I have know that.
I have no opinion on.